j'ai jamais porté le maillot du real
madrid si je les portais à 14 en une
semaine mais mais ils m'ont toujours
toujours acceptés comme l'un des leurs
et pour ça il faut il faut être
reconnaissant il faut savoir être
reconnaissant donc je veux juste déjà
les remercier je comprends je comprends
la déception mais j'espère qu'ils
comprendront le fait que j'ai choisi
j'ai choisi de rester dans mon pays
parce que voilà aujourd'hui il ya une
vérité c'est que je suis français et
comme j'ai dit comme j'ai dis en tant
que français j'ai envie de continuer
encore un peu essayé de mener la france
vers les sommets et d'essayer de tirer
ce championnat et et ce club